well
[Music]
how are you greetings from cristian cásseres with
his brief news now in
Spanish part of a
supermarket structure collapsed on Friday
morning one of the branches of the
beautiful super marker located in
tension fences on south avenue  collapsed
according to the
cork county fire department four people
were injured including one of
them was rescued from the rubble
and all are expected to recover and
al dijon state will open its gates for the
first time for the
pre-season match of the  kingdoms on saturday night
the team will face asia
for the first time and with fans this
creates some challenges in terms of
traffic and parking for which
it is recommended to arrive several hours
before the start of the game now
some options you have is to
Through the public system you can
obtain a bus pass for only eight
über dollars and they can increase your
prices due to  gone on demand visit news
now dotcom for more options
hitler joins
las vegas zero fatality coalition to offer
discount rides to
riders game thousand riders were
can get ten dollars off
using the words riders
smartphones the  credit will only be for
this Saturday starting at noon
and we will have temperatures close to
105 degrees by this Friday
sunny skies for the valley however there will be
a slight chance of rain in the
mountains the lake and some parts of the
valley the extreme heat will return for
this purpose  of the week I am Cristian Cásseres
with his brief informative news now in
Spanish good day
[Music]